where we left off we were trying our
very best to get to the castle and save
whomever we were needing to save
but we had to cross the bridge and the
troll gave us these clues because we had
no money in our pocket and if we don't
solve his riddle he's going to push us
into the water so we are we're we we are
under pressure and at least we made some
headway in the last video we were able
to represent his clues mathematically as
a system of equations what i want to do
in this video is think about whether we
can solve for this system of equations
and you will see that there are many
ways of solving a system of a system of
equations but this time i want to do it
visually because at least in my mind it
helps really kind of get the intuition
of what these things are saying
so let's draw some axes over here let's
draw
an f axis that's the number of fives
that i have and let's draw a t-axis that
is the number of tens i have and let's
say that this right over here this right
over here is five hundred tens
that is one thousand tens
and let's say that this is sorry that's
five hundred fives that's one thousand
fives
this is five hundred tens
five 500 tens and this is one thousand
tens
so let's think about all of the
combinations of f's and t's that satisfy
this first equation
if t if we have no tens then we're going
to have 900 fives
so if we have no tens we're gonna have
five we have 905 so that looks like it's
right about there so that's the point
zero tens nine hundred
nine hundred fives but what if it went
the other way if we have no fives we're
going to have 900 tens
so it's going to be that's going to be
the point 900 tens
zero fives so all the combinations of
f's and t's that satisfy this are going
to be on this line are going to be on
that line right over there and i just
draw a dotted line just because it's
easier for me to draw it straight so
that represents all the f's and t's that
satisfy the first constraint obviously
there's a bunch of them so we don't know
which is the one that is actually what
the troll has but lucky for us we have a
second constraint this one right over
here so let's do the same thing
in this constraint what happens if we
have no tens
if tens are zero then we have five f is
equal to fifty 5500 let me write do a
little table here because this is a
little bit more involved
it's a little bit more involved so for
the second equation
tens and fives if i have no tens if i
have no tens i have five f is equal to
5500 f will be 1100
f is i must have 1100 fives
if i have no fives if i have no fives
and this is zero and if 10t is equal to
5500 that means i have 550
50 10. so let's plot both of this point
t equals zero f is eleven hundred that's
right about there
so that is zero
eleven hundred is on the line that
represents this equation and that when f
is 0 t is 550. so let's see this is
about see this would be 6
7 8 9 so 550 is going to be right over
here so that is the point
550 comma zero and all of these
all of these points let me draw try to
draw a straight line again i can do a
better job than that
i can do a better job than that so all
of these points
are the points let me try one more time
one more time we want to get this right
we don't want to get pushed into the
water by the troll
so there you go that looks pretty good
so every every point on this blue line
represents an ft combination that
satisfies the second constraint
so what is an f and t or number of fives
and number of tens that satisfy both
constraints well it would be a point
that is sitting on both of the lines and
what is a point that is sitting on both
of the lines well that's where they
intersect this point right over here is
clearly on the blue line and it is
clearly on the yellow line
and what we can do is if we drew this
graph really really really precisely we
could see how many
fives that is and how many tens that is
and if you look at it if you look at it
very precisely and actually i encourage
you to graph it very precisely and come
up with how many fives and how many tens
that is
well when we do it right over here i'm
going to eyeball it if we look at it
right over here it looks like we have
about seven hundred fives
seven hundred fives and it looks like we
have about two hundred tens and this is
based on my really rough graph but let's
see if that worked 700 plus 200 700 plus
200 is equal to 900
and if i have 705 700 let me write this
down
5 times 700 is going to be the value of
the fives which is 3500
and then 10
plus 10 times 200
10 times 200 which is 2 000.
thousand dollars is the value of the
tens and if you add up the two values
you indeed get two fifty five hundred
dollars so this looks right and so we
can tell the troll troll i know i know
how many five and ten dollar bills you
have you have seven hundred five dollar
bills and you have two hundred ten
dollar bills
the troll is impressed and he lets you
cross the bridge to
be the hero or heroine of this fantasy
adventure